[Música]
y
poniéndolo digamos en términos médicos
podríamos decir que es una molestia
crónica la corrupción en américa latina'
sigue demostrando que se resiste a
desaparecer y que es prácticamente parte
del funcionamiento de los estados y
también del día a día de las sociedades
latinoamericanas es habitualmente uno de
los temas que más sobresalen en las
campañas electorales muchos candidatos
dicen ser los abanderados de la lucha
anti corrupción pero es poco lo que este
problema se reduce digámoslo así
mientras que las consecuencias cada día
son más grandes y más evidentes el
índice de capacidad para combatir la
corrupción es una publicación que evalúa
la capacidad precisamente que tienen los
países de américa latina para detectar
castigar y prevenir la corrupción en su
informe del 2022 pese a haber descendido
en algunos indicadores uruguay lidera la
región superando ampliamente en las
diferentes categorías evaluadas como por
ejemplo democracia e instituciones
políticas sociedad civil y medios de
comunicación costa rica presenta una
mejora en sus indicadores
entonces al segundo lugar por encima de
chile estos tres países los vamos a
analizar en unos minutos con nuestros
invitados en el fondo de la lista como
ustedes lo ven el panorama cambia poco
está guatemala bolivia y venezuela que
son los países que pese a haber visto
algunas modificaciones haber realizado
algunos ajustes y avances pues siguen
siendo los que están de últimos en la
región con un largo camino por recorrer
todavía para poder empezar a superar
algunos de los problemas más básicos si
lo comparamos con otros países de la
región lo vamos a analizar también en
unos minutos con nuestros invitados
si tu entonces parte de este informe al
decir que el objetivo de este índice no
es avergonzar o discriminar a los países
de la región lo que intentan hacer es
fomentar que se abra una discusión para
buscar políticas públicas que le permita
a los gobiernos de turno también a la
sociedad entre otros actores buscar los
mecanismos necesarios para poder
combatir la corrupción a través de
puntos importantes como por ejemplo
identificación de las deficiencias de
cada uno de los países cuál es entonces
la perspectiva general de la región de
américa latina en torno a la corrupción
es la corrupción un tema que tiene
solución en el largo plazo o ya es parte
fundamental del funcionamiento del
estado de la dinámica de la sociedad
latinoamericana cuáles son las buenas
prácticas que le han funcionado a países
como por ejemplo uruguay costa rica y
chile como los mencionaba que son los
líderes en el ranking por eso hoy en el
debate de france 24 la lucha contra la
corrupción en américa latina' es nuestro
tema de análisis y para conversar sobre
este tema saludamos a brian winter él es
vicepresidente del consejo de las
américas él se encuentra en la ciudad de
nueva york en los eeuu
el estudio de france 24 nos acompaña
silvana amaya ella es analista senior de
control risks ella se encuentra pues por
supuesto aquí con nosotros en el estudio
de france 24 para conversar sobre este
tema les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas y también los
comentarios que deseen hacer en las
redes sociales les recuerdo estamos en
twitter estamos en instagram y en
facebook en donde no se encuentran como
france24
s arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate efe 24
también en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming también los invito
para que escuchen el podcast de nuestro
programa nuestro contenido ya está
disponible en app el podcast en spotify
deezer gentium pues bien comenzamos
entonces poniendo en perspectiva como me
gusta decirlo el punto de partida la
primera pregunta me gusta llamarla así
comienzo entonces con silvana aquí en el
estudio de france24 silvana gracias por
acompañarnos bienvenida al programa
y panorama general de este informe y de
la región en general para conocer
posiciones y de ahí en adelante comenzar
en el análisis de algunos de los países
con muchísimas gracias pues si la idea
de este informe es de alguna manera
comparar estos 15 países de américa
latina hoy tomamos 14 diferentes
variables en tres grandes categorías y
la idea que nosotros tenemos acá es como
dice el informe como ya lo dije si tú no
es avergonzar a los países no es que
ellos se sientan digamos mal por los
resultados de este informe sino al revés
puedan observar buenas prácticas en
otros países y por qué no cooperar entre
ellos la idea es precisamente resaltar
cuáles son esas capacidades de cada uno
de los estados para combatir eficazmente
la corrupción y es que herramientas dan
buenos resultados la corrupción
desafortunadamente y en algunos aspectos
tendemos a verlo como exclusivo de los
estados pero esto tal vez no es correcto
y por eso una de nuestras categorías
incluye a la sociedad civil como la
sociedad civil exige un poco que la
corrupción no sobrepase digamos estos
y como además la sociedad si puede jugar
un rol importante en combatir la misma
corrupción como de alguna manera
manifestándose en contra de ésta y
también el rol de los medios de
comunicación que resulta una categoría
también muy interesante que algunos de
los países de hecho mostraron una
mejoría significativa en la en el rol
que juegan los medios de comunicación
pero que vemos que todavía hay un campo
muy grande por seguir mejorando y por
seguir realmente teniendo unas
herramientas mucho más eficaces contra
la corrupción punto de vista de silvana
nuestra invitada aquí en el estudio le
pregunto en nuestro punto de partida a
bryant winter en la ciudad de nueva york
el punto de partida panorama general de
la región de acuerdo a este informe su
perspectiva de el significado de la
corrupción del estado de la corrupción
en los estados latinoamericanos y en las
sociedades latinoamericanas
bueno buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación y primero antes que nada
reiterar que este índice no mide los
niveles o los niveles percibidos de
corrupción sino que mide la capacidad de
los países de prevenir poner y detectar
la corrupción y lo que vimos este año
fue una mezcla de cosas por un lado
vemos tanto en américa latina como en
otros lugares del mundo del mundo como
en eeuu donde es de donde te hablo hoy
que temas como anti corrupción en varios
países han pasado a segundo plano
obviamente vivimos una situación
emergencia en los últimos dos años por
causa de la pandemia y ahora en 2022 la
pandemia a sus efectos han disminuido
pero vemos consecuencias como es doctor
notoria en el caso de la inflación
estenosis en varios países el énfasis
que hubo en el atlántico corrupción que
vivimos en países como brasil perú
panamá guatemala y otros en la última
parte de la última década en años como
2018 2019 antes de la pandemia ahora
paso a hacer una cuestión secundaria
planning a pesar de a pesar de eso
vivimos en muchos países que todavía hay
un esfuerzo para hacer reformas que
puedan mejorar un poco la situación y
vimos
cuatro países países que subieron
significativamente
4 que bajaron y el resto más o menos se
mantuvieron claras bueno te voy a mirar
primero de forma general este informe a
mirar la región de forma general y luego
vamos a mirar algunos casos específicos
de unos países que llaman la atención
bryant continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa mencionaba usted la
pandemia de 2019 la inflación esta
reactivación económica que le está
costando a algunos países de la región
esto que tanto influye en esos
indicadores que ustedes han evaluado
para
e informe porque la pandemia todavía
persiste la inflación todavía se está
presentando en la mayoría de los países
y hay un descontento general lo vemos
por ejemplo en las manifestaciones que
tienen lugar en las calles de diferentes
ciudades latinoamericanas en rechazo a
políticas de los gobiernos precisamente
para poder salir adelante en el tema
económico
te diría aquí la preocupación por la
inflación
por ejemplo influye indirectamente en el
índice porque simplemente porque crea
otras prioridades para el gobierno y
también para la gente no o sea vemos una
onda de manifestaciones en américa
latina en este momento por el precio del
petróleo en países como guatemala
brasil-colombia inclusive en años
anteriores vimos protestas por la
corrupción contra el gobierno y eso
ahora ese panorama se ha modificado un
poco pero ustedes que están en colombia
saben perfectamente que tampoco o sea
también no dejó de ser un tema de hecho
en algunas encuestas para la elección
presidencial en colombia que acaba de
terminar y vimos que la corrupción
todavía figuraba en primer lugar entre
los electores entonces eso es un
contraste en lo que vemos en países como
chile y brasil donde ya no es un tema
tan importante
y tal vez un ejemplo más que américa
latina es una región bastante variada
bastante diversa muy diversa si ya lo
decía yo en la introducción del programa
para muchos candidatos a la hora de
promover ideas a través de sus campañas
políticas se muestran como los
abanderados de la lucha contra la
corrupción pero a la hora de ponerlo en
práctica le cuesta mucho algunas veces
llevarlo a la práctica silván aquí en el
estudio de france 24 también citando una
parte de este informe dice que en
general los poderes judiciales y también
los organismos anti corrupción de
algunos países de américa latina han
tenido muchas dificultades para poder
desarrollar estos planes y estas ideas
anticorrupción si lo comparamos con la
década pasada cuál es la diferencia que
es lo que ha hecho distinta a la década
pasada ya está en el contexto político o
social en que estamos que ha sido
difícil de implementarlo yo creo que uno
de los temas es exactamente la
independencia de estos órganos y es cada
vez es más difícil poder observar y
mantener esa independencia como decía
brian ahorita normalmente la corrupción
se mide por percepción y nosotros
tratamos de alejarnos de esto nos
alejamos de estudio 'la porque lo que
medimos es la capa realmente que tienen
las instituciones para combatir la
corrupción para encontrar esos casos de
corrupción y en ese sentido es muy
importante que tan independiente están
estos órganos no solo órganos como la
fiscalía en los diferentes países la
procuraduría dependiendo de cómo esté
digamos establecido cada uno de los
estados que puede variar un poco entre
los países de la región pero sobre todo
también las agencias anticorrupción que
tanto presupuesto tienen de dónde están
sacando esa financiación son
independientes a quién le deben rendir
cuentas y en ese sentido digamos se
resalta la diferencia entre las décadas
porque tal vez se garantizaba más esa
independencia antes ahora digamos que la
diferencia y los pesos y contrapesos
entre los poderes resulta más difícil
cuando además estamos en situaciones
geopolíticas o económicas o sociales que
construyen un poco eso la pandemia es
uno de los grandes ejemplos lo que
estamos viendo ahorita con la inflación
digamos que nos llega de la situación
mundial que estamos viviendo frente a la
invasión de rusia ucrania o la digamos
del cierre de china que también conlleva
con eso muchísimos
implicaciones en la economía de los
países estamos por ejemplo ahorita ni
con unas protestas muy fuertes y la
corrupción digamos que muchas veces no
se presenta como la bandera principal
pero está intrínseca en esos movimientos
sociales de protestas porque las
personas se dan cuenta que se sigue
siendo permanentemente uno de los
problemas y creo que otras situaciones
que muchas veces se quedan en el
discurso entonces esa independencia que
no tienen las entidades para investigar
y para fallar o juzgar estos casos es
precisamente porque se queda en el
discurso y no pasa a la práctica silvana
pero entonces este tema deja de ser
prioridad usted dice que está en
tránsito en muchos de los reclamos de
las sociedades bryant dice que en
algunos países como chile o brasil no
fue uno de los grandes temas de las
campañas recientes o no ha sido uno de
los grandes temas de discusión política
recientemente pero por ejemplo en
colombia si fue uno de los motivos de
bandera de uno de los candidatos que
aspiraba la presidencia es necesario en
el momento en el que estamos tratar como
de revivir ese sentimiento para la lucha
contra la corrupción en las sociedades
latinoamericanas o se está perdiendo esa
fuerza por parte de la sociedad y luego
mirémoslo desde la de los estados
también a los estados de pronto les
conviene un poco un poco el tono al tema
claro y es interesante porque ahí es
difícil digamos comparar cada país es
único y es independiente colombia tal
cual lo vivió ahorita y no solamente
porque un candidato lideró ese discurso
de la de la lucha contra la corrupción
sino porque cada una de las encuestas
que vimos anterior a las a las
elecciones en cada una de las etapas del
proceso electoral cuando se le
preguntaba a los colombianos cuál era la
preocupación mayor siempre salía a
relucir la corrupción entonces es un
problema que efectivamente a la gente le
preocupa y le molesta porque mucha gente
dice algo así como a mi no me importa
pagar impuestos mientras no se lo roben
pero si uno siente que los recursos que
se están recolectando para los
diferentes programas sociales para los
diferentes
lo que se invierte digamos en el sector
público no se ve no se ven resultados
ahí es cuando la gente entra en un
choque fuerte pero evidentemente eso no
es lo mismo en otros países hay otros
países como chile donde el el proceso
constituyente ocupó la mayoría de la
agenda política y de alguna manera eso
relegó el tema de la corrupción tal vez
es una sociedad que percibe con menor
intensidad la corrupción y que no le
preocupa en brasil digamos es un caso
que llama la atención y es porque siendo
brasil un país que tiene una fama
digamos de corrupción digamos la
percepción pero además lo vemos
inclusión calores históricos que
demuestran una alta corrupción en todas
las instancias además destaparon un tema
muy fuerte que se rodó por toda américa
latina donde en todos los de la vall
hato fue digamos un dominó un efecto
dominó en todos los países de américa
latina
pero perdón pero no vimos como una
reacción lo suficientemente fuerte y ahí
es lo que tú decías pues los estados de
alguna manera se benefician de esta
reacción y no tan fuerte no tan
emblemática de decir de solicitar
digamos exigir rendición de cuentas por
parte de los estados y decir cómo vamos
a combatir la corrupción y qué efectos
digamos qué medidas concretas vamos como
estado a adaptar para que las
instituciones gocen de mayor
independencia y de mayor financiación y
herramientas para realmente tener
resultados que piensa bryant en la
ciudad de nueva york es necesario
revivir este sentimiento de lucha contra
la corrupción a nivel de la sociedad
latinoamericana se está perdiendo ese
entusiasmo esos reclamos que veíamos en
escenarios anteriores y bueno la misma
pregunta que silvana también a los
estados les conviene en cierta forma que
los escándalos pasen un poco por debajo
de la cuerda
me parece ilógico que en momentos cuando
tenemos la inflación más alta en 40 años
aquí en eeuu y en países como chile ya
ha sido un tema recurrente en toda la
región
que la gente tenga otras preocupaciones
pero yo creo que sí por otro lado les
corresponde tanto a las autoridades
gubernamentales como la sociedad civil
la prensa y otros seguir levantando ese
tema para el bienestar de mediano y
largo plazo de todos vemos en este
momento un giro para la izquierda en
muchos países de hecho en la mayoría de
los países del hemisferio que ha sido
muy comentado y confirmado ahora con la
elección de gustavo petro pero no puede
haber justicia social y corrupción al
mismo tiempo porque sabemos que la
corrupción le saca recursos a los
programas sociales
también crea distorsiones en las
licitaciones públicas obras de
infraestructura notoriamente pero
también en otros casos entonces para el
bien de los países es un mal que
necesita
ser combatido nosotros desarrollamos el
índice con humildad para llamar la
atención a este tema y también a las
políticas eficaces de hacerlo
bryant silvana dos preguntas más en
torno a este informe de manera general
paso a preguntarles entonces por los
medios de comunicación en una región
como américa latina en donde son pocos
países los que tienen medios de
comunicación públicos fuertes que sean
líderes en el manejo de la opinión en
esas sociedades donde la mayoría de los
medios de comunicación pertenecen a
grandes conglomerados económicos que a
su vez algunos tienen cercanía con los
gobiernos de turno en otros no
dependiendo de la alternancia que haya
el papel de los medios acá también para
entender qué es lo que estamos haciendo
nosotros comienzo a comprar en ya le doy
la palabra silvana
mira el periodismo investigativo
especialmente es un factor súper
importante en el índice que consideramos
y que le damos bastante peso porque
sabemos que el periodismo investigativo
tiene la capacidad de detectar los
grandes casos de corrupción como ha sido
el caso en en casos como el escándalo la
línea en guatemala y la casa blanca en
méxico esos fueron casos grandes de la
década pasada y sabemos por ejemplo que
él trabaja de que el periodismo
investigativo continúa haciendo un gran
trabajo en argentina en chile en brasil
y en otros países es un factor
importante
sabemos que el periodismo ha sufrido en
países como brasil en los últimos años
por presión de las autoridades con con
ataques constantes al periodismo en
general también hay un efecto comercial
que es real donde muchos diarios
especialmente están perdiendo
suscriptores
y por eso no tienen la misma capacidad
de hacer reportajes que tenían antes
pero a pesar de eso es el factor y la
democracia en general se ha mostrado
resistente en la mayor parte de la
región y hay casos importantes en la
región por ejemplo el tema de la censura
en nicaragua que no entra en este
balance en este informe no hay una
evaluación de nicaragua bueno venezuela
pues también es un caso y también ve una
sintonía en estos indicadores países
como por ejemplo costa rica que también
es el que lidera la libertad de prensa a
nivel de nuestra región pues están en
segundo lugar en este tema de cómo
afrontar los diferentes aspectos que
envuelven a la corrupción silvana
opinión sobre los vencí es interesante y
digamos lo vemos un poquito con el
índice que precisamente países como
guatemala bolivia venezuela tienen
muchísima menos libertad de expresión y
libertad de los medios de comunicación
ha habido censura en venezuela es una de
las constantes críticas de la oposición
la censura que además ya ha permanecido
durante muchos años y cada vez es pues
digamos no hay una forma de mejorar esa
libertad de expresión
los medios de comunicación sin duda pues
han liderado procesos investigativos
importantes acá en colombia por ejemplo
el tema de centros poblados fue de
gracias a periodismo investigativo de
una de las cadenas digamos más
importantes de colombia y lo respaldaron
muchos otros medios bueno más
recientemente la financiación del del
acuerdo de paz que es lo que se va a
encontrar el presidente pero tan pronto
llegue que no va a haber fondos para la
implementación del acuerdo porque la
plata se esfumó exactamente entonces
todo esto gracias a que los medios
juegan un rol fundamental dentro de la
democracia cuando nosotros vemos que tan
débil o qué tan fuerte es una democracia
ese es uno de los indicadores más
importantes y lo mismo es para la lucha
contra la corrupción y además hay un
punto importante y es que hay medios
alternativos de comunicación digamos
diferentes a los tradicionales que han
empezado a sobrellevar un rol más
importante donde también juegan un papel
para
investigar y denunciar estos casos de
corrupción y estos medios que además se
apoyan mucho en las redes sociales que
también son juegan un rol fundamental en
esto de alguna manera han logrado que en
los últimos años ese rol juegos sea cada
vez más importante y respalde cada vez
más estas capacidades de la lucha contra
la corrupción y esa forma en que la
sociedad civil se entere de qué está
pasando y exija rendición de cuentas a
un alto costo por ejemplo méxico que ya
en seis siete meses del 2022 ya es el
año más mortífero para la prensa en este
país 12 periodistas han sido asesinados
a lo largo de este año por hacer
periodismo de investigación es un alto
precio que hay que pagar por informar en
algunos países pasemos entonces a ver
algunos de los casos que llaman la
atención de este informe después de
haber hecho esta vista en general a
grandes rasgos de lo que se comenta en
este informe quiero comenzar por el caso
de república dominicana que es tal vez
uno de los casos más positivos por
hablar acá de cosas buenas y no
solamente verlo desde el lado malo que
te deja la corrupción silvana caso a
república dominicana fue el país que vio
la mayor mejora en su puntuación y con
en una tendencia que viene presentando
en los dos últimos años así es
república dominicana paso del puesto
número 10 en el 2021 al quinto lugar en
el 2022 y es un país que ha mostrado
mucha iniciativa y que ha mejorado
muchos de sus indicadores de cómo
combatir la corrupción él tuvo una
mejoría en la capacidad legal para mes
para combatir la corrupción del 24 por
ciento esto realmente sorprende porque
es un país digamos chiquito pero que ha
invertido muchos recursos y sobre todo
intención política en precisamente hacer
tener estos logros y creo que es un
ejemplo muy interesante sobre todo para
otros países de centroamérica y del
caribe pero por qué no también países de
suramérica que miran y pueden aprender
de estas buenas prácticas que este
pequeño país ha tenido para mejorar con
su lucha con la corrupción voluntad
política un factor importante entonces
para destacar del caso dominicano
bryant desde su perspectiva que está
haciendo bien república dominicana que
pueda destacarse y ser de pronto visto
desde perspectiva en otros países
la clave para combatir y detectar la
corrupción no es un secreto es construir
instituciones independientes y
fortalecer la democracia y punto
básicamente y lo que vemos en la
república dominicana es que han mejorado
sus esfuerzos en ese sentido le han
dedicado más recursos a las
instituciones como en una oficina
anticorrupción que pueden ayudar con ese
trabajo también han mostrado que están
dando señales por lo menos de aplicar la
ley a todos porque seamos sinceros ha
habido países donde se usa los esfuerzos
anticorrupción como una herramienta
política para combatir sus adversarios
entonces algo que siempre tratamos de
considerar es si hay funcionarios tanto
del gobierno como de la oposición que
por lo menos están siendo investigados
seriamente que se está aplicando la ley
de una manera parece y si efectivamente
con lo que haciendo el presidente
abinader en en la república domnicana
hemos visto señales de eso entonces es
una es la historia de éxito o la
historia que más ha mejorado en los
últimos tres años bueno otro otra
historia de éxito y que vale la pena
traerlo aquí a la mesa para el análisis
es uruguay que lidera muchos rankings a
nivel internacional y a nivel de la
región tiene una puntuación de 7.42 bajo
un poco si se le compara con el año
anterior hay diferentes puntos para
analizar allí baja pero se mantiene la
primera posición bryant opinión sobre el
caso uruguayo una democracia que se ha
logrado consolidar recordemos que hace
unos 30 a 35 años uruguay estaba
saliendo de una dictadura y ha logrado
consolidar su régimen democrático con
alternancia de poder y sobre todo lo que
usted dice institucionalidad y
diferencia entre las diferentes
instituciones del estado
ha habido muchas preocupaciones sobre la
democracia en américa latina' los
últimos años y en muchos países están
más que justificadas pero reitero que
américa latina es una región muy diversa
y hay varios países como uruguay costa
rica chile y no por casualidad son los
países que están
primeros en este índice que realmente
son democracias de nivel mundial
inclusive como alguien que vive en los
eeuu
yo les tengo cierta envidia e incluyo el
caso colombiano aquí con el
reconocimiento rápido del resultado de
la elección reciente por parte del
candidato que perdió y no sólo eso sino
una visita bastante republicana entre
los dos candidatos de la segunda vuelta
que la historia de eeuu
muestra que claramente no hay que
valorizar esas cosas porque porque no
son automáticas lo que vemos con uruguay
es que es una democracia todavía
relativamente joven pero que ha
construido procesos
tiene varias instituciones que son
fuertes y es cierto que la puntuación
bajó un poco de este año pero no no no
no fue una baja muy relevante tiene que
ver con un cambio que hicieron en el
código legal que podría de
dificultar el trabajo de detectar lavado
de dinero siempre un tema en uruguay
porque es un centro financiero pero
igual si vemos la película y no
solamente la foto vemos que uruguay
sigue siendo una historia bastante
positiva para lógico silvana que en
uruguay una de las recomendaciones y
críticas que hace el informe es que hay
una persistente falta de financiación a
la principal agencia anti corrupción de
ese país que es la junta de
transparencia y ética pública sin
embargo lidera el 'ranking' si es
interesante porque uruguay logra
mantener su cultura política de lucha
contra la corrupción y de alguna manera
sus instituciones siguen siendo
independientes pero si resalta que el
tema de la financiación de la jutep que
es la junta de transparencia y ética no
es tan clara como va a continuar y esto
lo que también intenta hacer es de
alguna manera disparar esas pequeñas
alarmas como sabemos uruguay pues es el
que lidera no solamente este año sino en
los años anteriores el índice y que esto
sirva para que las autoridades uruguayas
pongan atención un poco este tema y creo
que la respuesta mediática que hemos
visto en uruguay es tal cual un poco
y resaltar el buen rol que ha jugado el
país en los últimos años que mantiene su
cultura política de lucha contra la
corrupción que mantiene la independencia
de las instituciones pero que de alguna
manera no se puede descuidar porque este
pequeño descenso pues de alguna manera
es sin olvidarnos el tema global que
uruguay tiene un gran desempeño pues
tiene que ser tenido en cuenta y tomado
por las por las autoridades pasemos al
caso de costa rica en este ranking logró
trepar si hasta el segundo puesto con
una puntuación de 711 tuvo un
crecimiento del 10 por ciento según este
reporte pero hay una particularidad y es
que allí tienen un gobierno nuevo
encabezado por rodrigo chávez en qué
hechos hay que prestarle la atención
allí en el caso de costa rica- silvana y
sobre todo con este cambio de gobierno
haya que ponerle la lupa a este país sí
es importante digamos que está rica
también ha tenido esta cultura política
muy fuerte de lucha contra la corrupción
y mantiene su independencia de las
autoridades pero de alguna manera si
sobresale por ejemplo el tema de las
investigaciones sobre presuntos esquemas
de corrupción en los temas de la
construcción e infraestructura este es
un tema que de alguna manera
sobresale y que la nueva administración
tendrá que ponerle la debida atención
que merece este este tema como estamos
viendo un cambio de régimen es posible
que tengamos digamos algunos nuevos
hallazgos
necesitan confirmar esa independencia de
las instituciones ese respeto por los
frenos y contrapesos que es lo que tal
vez los países que están entrando un
nuevo gobierno como lo son costa rica
colombia y próximamente brasil cuando
celebra sus elecciones en noviembre
tendrán que garantizar un poco cuáles va
a ser esa continuidad y si el presidente
tú no va a seguir respetando las
instituciones va a seguir respetando los
frenos y contrapesos pues creo que un
poco el reto de costa rica es ese si se
quiere mantener en ese segundo lugar y
si quiere digamos seguir con este
desempeño donde se garantiza más la
participación de los medios de
comunicación que es otra cátedra que
sobresale y la participación de la
sociedad civil un caso similar bryant es
el caso de chile que además de tener una
alternancia de poder pues también está
estrenando presidente digámoslo así cae
una posición en este en este ranking
pasa a la tercera posición costa rica lo
supera y queda en la segunda es un país
que está redactando una nueva
constitución va a haber una consulta en
septiembre para que sea aprobada pero
hay mucha expectativa en torno a lo que
puede ser el gobierno de gabriel boric
que se puede decir del caso chileno
bueno el caso el chileno
se destaca un poco porque hubo una
transición política reciente y algo que
notamos en el índice de este año es que
los países que han pasado por una
transición política se han mantenido en
el último año se han mantenido bastante
estables fue el caso con perú también yo
estuve en chile el mes pasado tuve
visitas con miembros de la oposición
funcionarios del gobierno y otros y
realmente me
impresiona
nuevamente la calidad de la democracia
en chile y el respeto para las
instituciones que todas las partes
chilenas tienen una sociedad que
obviamente fue muy traumatizada por la
dictadura que sufrió de augusto pinochet
es del 73 hasta el 90 y hay una nueva
generación que está asumiendo el poder
en este momento con gabriel por hecho un
presidente que sólo tiene 36 años pero
que se ha mantenido otra vez
y énfasis todavía a esa cuestión de la
institucionalidad y entonces que haya
una nueva constitución que haya un nuevo
gobierno no veo grandes cambios en el
sonograma anti-corrupción en chile de
hecho en esta nueva constitución van a
incluir medidas en materia de corrupción
y gobernanza y también la convención
constitucional aprobó 10 artículos para
esta propuesta de nueva constitución en
chile- que están relacionados con la
propiedad la transparencia y la
rendición de cuentas es importante
entonces hacerle seguimiento a lo que va
a pasar a partir de ahí sobre todo
porque también buscan un cambio en el
modelo del estado chileno y eso podría
generar entonces nuevas prácticas para
combatir la corrupción para estos
últimos minutos del programa quiero que
nos vayamos al fondo de la tabla los
tres países que están más relegados en
su lucha contra la corrupción estamos
hablando de venezuela estamos hablando
de guatemala estamos hablando de bolivia
en el último lugar está venezuela con
una puntuación de 163 hay serias
críticas por parte de organismos
internacionales en torno a temas como
los derechos humanos de hecho la cpi
dijo que va a estar allí instalando en
caracas una para para precisamente
seguir ahondando en los diferentes casos
que han visto allí que se puede decir
del caso venezolano para ya en un caso
que es muy crítico porque claramente la
independencia institucional es lo que
está más perjudicado y tal vez lo que
más se ha deteriorado en venezuela a lo
largo de los años
si el estado venezolano es una gran caja
negra no sabemos que está ahí adentro
sabemos que hay mucha penetración por el
narcotráfico por la corrupción por
frentes extranjeros que han permeado a
la dictadura y al final como dije si la
democracia es la clave
tener éxito en este índice de la escuela
siendo la dictadura más
fuerte y tal vez más cruel del
hemisferio no no debe ser una sorpresa
que se en último lugar y también es es
una historia hay que recordar un poco la
historia hable ahora de chile y la
construcción de la democracia que hacer
y aún me quedan tres minutos por favor
muy puntual
aunque no yo iba a dar énfasis en que
hace 30 años venezuela era considerada
una de las democracias más fuertes la
región entonces no hay que tomar nada
como si fuera natural y si siempre estar
vigente para la construcción de las
instituciones claro silván algo que
decir del caso venezolano y añado a la
pregunta el caso de bolivia que es el
que sigue hacia arriba en la lista
entonces serio señalamientos de que la
justicia pues claramente está siendo
utilizada simplemente para juzgar a
algunos y no para todos que era un punto
que estaba hablando bryant al inicio el
programa y rápidamente venezuela sólo
que es difícil también acceder a la
información la información es cero
transparente o poco transparente y es
difícil confiar en la información que se
tiene entonces esto es uno de los
problemas que digamos también se tienen
no solamente para construir un índice
como éste que tuvimos de alguna manera
problemas metodológicos de lograr
entender y por eso hay unas de las
categorías que ni siquiera tienen un
resultado
y pasando yo a bolivia claro bolivia
también ocupa el segundo lugar digamos
de abajo para arriba y presenta muy
pocas mejorías en varios de los digamos
en pocos de los índices sobresale que la
independencia judicial efectivamente no
es algo que se garantiza y que solamente
en ciertos casos actúa pero de alguna
manera con intención política
y no permite que las autoridades
bolivianas muestren ese mensaje de
transparencia y hay muchas dudas sobre
los procesos judiciales que se llevan y
los medios de comunicación tampoco son
lo suficientemente fuertes para hacer
para cuestionar estas decisiones o estos
procesos o para hacer periodismo de
investigación me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa me toca dejar por
fuera el caso de guatemala en paso
preguntarle para las conclusiones bryant
la pregunta que muchas personas se hacen
se puede solucionar el tema de la
corrupción se puede reversar el daño que
ha causado la corrupción a lo largo de
estas décadas en américa latina' su
conclusión rápidamente y muy puntual por
favor la corrupción siempre iba a
existir pero es una cuestión relativa en
la historia reciente de américa latina'
y si claramente es posible muchos países
han logrado disminuir la corrupción y
mejorar su capacidad de combatirla y
nuestro índice busca un poco celebrar
esos casos
silvana para el cierre con cluj y se
puede es necesario invertir en el tema
no solamente en recursos financieros
sino en recursos políticos de intención
política pero también necesitamos
acompañarlo con educación para que la
gente reconozca que es un acto de
corrupción que no y cómo mejorar desde
la sociedad civil tanto exigirle al
estado como mejorar el comportamiento y
garantizar además la transparencia y la
vitalidad de los medios de comunicación
para hacer estas investigaciones que
ayudan a un entorno más transparente
pues con esta reflexión cerramos el
programa le agradezco a bryant a silvana
por haber estado con nosotros haber
hecho el análisis de este informe para
toda la audiencia en américa latina'
ustedes pueden seguir dejando los
comentarios y preguntas que deseen a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]